il a été malgré lui l'une des stars de
l'actualité en 2019 qui joao ce paisible
retraité de 69 ans que la france entière
a pris l'espace de quelques heures pour
xavier dupont de ligonnès en raison d'un
cafouillage grotesque entre polices
française et autorités écossaises en
octobre dernier alors qu'il souhaitait
se rendre en france depuis l'aéroport de
glasgow d'où sa femme est originaire les
autorités locales ont procédé à un
contrôle et en ont conclu qu'il
s'agissait en réalité de xavier dupont
de ligonnès ce père de famille qui
aurait assassiné toute sa famille à
nantes en 2011
placé en détention provisoire il aura
fallu 26 heures à la police pour
comprendre son erreur
aujourd'hui guy joao ne s'est toujours
pas remis de cette affaire étrange au
coeur de laquelle il s'est retrouvé
malgré lui quatre mois après les faits
il a décidé de saisir la justice pour
comprendre ce qu'il s'est passé et
comment ce cafouillage at il pu se
produire
s'il avait déjà pris un avocat en écosse
les autorités locales avaient tenté de
se justifier mais sans jamais s'excuser
l'homme devrait déposer plainte dans les
jours à venir et espère obtenir de la
justice toutes les réponses qu'il n'aura
pas reçu de la part de la police
[Musique]
alors gilles il faut savoir que déjà
aujourd'hui quand la photo de quelqu'un
et publiée dans un journal sans son
autorisation il ya des avocats qui
viennent voir cette personne et qu'il
lui dise porte plainte on va gagner 10
15000 euros bien sûr pour monsieur guy
joao il ya évidemment des avocats
écossais et français qui sont venus
lourds à qui lui en dit on va gagner des
millions d'euros alors c'est sûr c'est
légitime parce que sa vie a été foutu en
l'air il a été mis très vous rendez
compte comme un tueur innommable royal
donc il va vous y doit être très
traumatisée me traumatiser alors y
portent plainte en écosse après en
france le problème c'est contre qui se
retourner mais parce qu'à une enquête
parc de la police des polices pour
savoir d'où vient la fuite est ce que
j'ai la vision du secret de
l'instruction et après peut-être contre
les médias dans un deuxième temps et là
ça peut faire très mal j'espère qu'ils
seront toujours aimées bien là ça va
mais je suis cipn mais son nom après
qu'on a révélé que ce n'est pas xavier
dupont de ligonnès ont continué de
montrer sa maison à un groupe d heure
après avec l'adresse la rue la vivacité
ou jusqu'à l'angle en décembre dernier
donc gi joe avait accepté de se confier
sur m6 et il réalisait encore à peine ce
qui s'était passé il raconté notamment
comment l'arrestation s'était passé et
c'est ça aussi qui fait que voilà lui il
est naturellement ni de rien le pauvre
il doit être traumatisé regarde
premier contact c'est assez brutal petit
policiers gardes frontières assez
agressif écrit faux passeport très vite
on l'amène dans une salle pour lui
annoncer qu'il est sous le coup d'un
mandat d'arrêt international
lorsqu'on m'a dit que j'étais un
criminel un assassin
j'ai bon pas de problème je n'ai jamais
tué personne
donc deux policiers me prenne moi même
me mettre les menottes et moi emmène me
mettre dans un petit fourgon de police
mais dans la science fiction alors voilà
donc c'était pour vous montrer un qu'il
était extrêmement marqué quand même
quand il peut demander s'il a votre avis
ridgway
à mon avis sur l'ensemble des médias et
puis après imaginons il peut aussi
attaquer l'état français il peut
attaquer les institutions je pense qu'il
peut demander plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros je pense aussi qu'il
faut demander à mon avis 400000 euros
total d'accord en france est un acquis
sont qui sont mis en prison
ses rares erreurs ils sont libérés ou
deux sans trois en une touche
pratiquement rien alors qu'ils ont gâché
trois ans c'est incroyable